es sind schwere zeit meine damen und
herren auch für deutschlands kommunen
wegen lockdown brechen die
steuereinnahmen weg klar rund 134
milliarden beträgt der schuldenstand der
gemeinden im dritten quartal 2020 heißt
übersetzt
demnächst wird wieder gespart bei
schwimmbädern an der schulsanierung bei
der kultur am luxus kram halt leider so
was in der angespannten lage echt
wichtig wäre dass seine kommune ihr geld
extrem konservativ an legt die queen
soll bank in bremen hat nach
informationen des wirtschaftskurses
heute nacht insolvenz angemeldet das
problem bei green so einige deutsche
kommunen hatten geld dort deponiert doch
nun ist klar die band ist nicht mehr zu
retten
green soll bank wir versenken ihr geld
über 50 deutsche kommunen haben
höchstwahrscheinlich rund 500 millionen
verloren
eine halbe milliarde von unserem geld in
der krisenlage bis zu 0,3 prozent zinsen
sollte es bei green sinn geben das war
das versprechen
jetzt ist der laden insolvent ist eine
ganz wichtige regel bitte mit schreiben
jede bank die mir heutzutage mehr als
nichts anbietet ist unseriös wie erkläre
ich ihnen die zahlen nichts anders wenn
ihnen jemand mehr anbietet als auf
diesem teller ist oder in diesem
portemonnaie oder in diesem lkw der
eigentlich impfstoff nach deutschland
bringen sollte dann bringen sie ihr geld
ganz schnell lieber zur sparkasse oder
so jetzt die schlechte nachricht genau
da zahlt man ab einem bestimmten betrag
heute - zinsen
das geld wird weniger deswegen werden
die kamera von wohlhabenderen kommunen
kreativ und verbrennen die steuer kohle
zum beispiel bei der green soll banken
positiv zinsen ohne risiko gibt es nicht
mehr
bittere erkenntnis gerade für uns
deutsche als spar weltmeister
jessica bist du jetzt total bescheuert
du sparst dir dein eigenes geld sparen
ist nur was für dumme kauf aktien kaufen
sonst habe ich nicht mehr nach jessica
so dumm
schon wieder ein finanzskandal in
deutschland gab es dann keine hinweise
oder indizien das gewinsel irgendwie
halbseidene sachen macht zumindest der
gründer macht doch einen top soliden
eindruck
der australische selfmade-milliardär lex
greencell war 2014 die bremische nf band
und benannte sie nach sich selbst sie
diente ihm seitdem als praktisches
werkzeug
er finanzierte damit was auch immer er
wollte allein vier privat jets im jahr
2015 vier privatjet oder wie friedrich
merz sagen würde
gehobener mittelstand hey was soll meine
wir haben doch in deutschland unsere
einlagensicherung wissen sie ja wenn
eine bank abschmiert kriegen alle ihr
geld zurück alle außer institutionelle
anleger und kommunen ja tatsächlich
hätten zehn minuten googeln gereicht und
bei der krisenbank skeptisch zu werden
zwischen 2017 und 19 ist deren
bilanzsumme um das zehnfache gestiegen
und schon im letzten sommer gab es bei
bloomberg diesen artikel
die bank des milliardärs kriens il wird
behördlich überprüft auch andere haben
darüber berichtet wie gesagt wir
bekommen einmal googeln hätte gereicht
und genau wie nachdem wirecard skandal
stellt sich auch hier die frage wozu
gibts ratingagenturen wenn die so was
nie kommen sehen und was macht unsere
bankenaufsicht eigentlich beruflich das
sollte doch nach wirecard alles besser
werden heute stelle ich ihnen meine
pläne für die reform der bafin vor
ich will eine finanzaufsicht mit biss
und mit viel mehr biss kann man diese
kampfansage beim besten willen nicht
vortragen mehr biss wie viel biss hatte
die bafin denn bis jetzt bearbeitet da
die 2700 mitarbeiter aber nur fünf
eigene wirtschaftsprüfer und wenn sie
sich fragen was haben die anderen
gelernt da sind viele
theaterwissenschaftler dabei breakdancer
bademeister sowas die bafin hat
monatelang gegen die green deal bank
ermittelt monate lang darf aber laut
gesetz betroffene anleger nicht waren
eine halbe milliarde kommunen geld ist
vermutlich futsch klar das trifft
natürlich vor allem wohlhabende
gemeinden ist ja logisch die geld übrig
haben wiesbaden zum beispiel schwalbach
im taunus oder monheim
ja monheim am rhein hätte seine 38
greensville millionen genauso gut in den
rhein werfen können als anlage nicht
schlechter doch gerade die monheimer
erreicht in diesen tagen auch viel häme
denn monheim ist tatsächlich eine
steueroase früher selber verschuldet
dann haben sie gewerbe und grundsteuer
gesenkt und seitdem läuft der laden in
monheim auf kosten von ärmeren kommunen
mit höheren steuern aber egal
in der not wird nicht kleinlich
aufgerechnet sollen geholfen
ich weiß genau was sie jetzt denken
wieso ist der kämmerer von monheim bitte
so verdammt gut an ihr zu warum sieht er
so viel geld aus als die kamera von den
anderen loser städten ganz einfach
monheim
weidmann
fußbodenheizung blattgold normale städte
am kanal raten wir haben kann ein nerze
wohnbereich unsere penner akzeptieren
alle gängigen kreditkarten
hier macht 2000 das geheimnis wir sind
eine steueroase
so lockt man firmen an hier auch sehr
chemie hatte mal seinen sitz im
bankrotten oberhausen
jetzt haben wir die aber jetzt ist mein
wort ganz blödes passiert böse banker
bremen 38 millionen gebracht
[Musik]
wir brauchen jeden cent für unsere
scheuren kunstprojekte wir haben den
künstlichen geysir im kreisverkehr
geborgen guck mal da kommt so was
deswegen helfen sie einer vollkommen
selbst verschuldet in not geratenen
zocker kommune und steueroase spenden
sie für monheim und unsere nächsten
projekte der künstlicher vulkan der
dreimal am tag vor karstadt ausbricht
der vergoldete fahrradweg nach
leverkusen und der sommermode werk aus
reinem kokain koks unser spendenkonto
ist nicht mehr in bremen sondern auf den
cayman-inseln einfach cool
[Musik]
so aufnahme hallo
dies ist die automatische and cut von
oliver welke und der heute show
leider ist das video schon vorbei ihr
könnt den kanal allerdings gerne
abonnieren und ein weiteres video
anschauen vielen dank so müsse jetzt für
immer reich